the return of a legend ladies and
gentlemen start your engines
okay well that was a sound the melody
affords all new shelby mustang gt350
it's powered by a 5.2 liter v8 engine
producing more than 500 horsepower and
the muscle car made its debut this week
at the LA auto show for more on what's
under the hood who emerged Matt Miller
in LA with joão Henriques before
President of the Americas Matt take it
away yeah not just a v8 but that's a
flat plane crank so it's a really
interesting motor and I definitely want
to talk to Joe about that but let's be a
little bit too in the weeds I think for
right now and first I have to ask about
Takata because that was really a
bombshell yesterday even the idea that
manufacturers would only recall cars in
regions where it's humid it's almost
laughable I mean what do you think about
this airbag issue well of course taking
care of customers is our top priority so
we're going to evaluate everything that
this is provided to us to say look at
all day to all of our data as well and
we're going to cooperate but also
remember there's a lot of new
information coming about this we want to
make sure that we all make the right do
the right thing for our customers and
quickly be given what's happening if you
decide though I mean if you're sitting
in the boardroom and you say this this
supplier is not working out for us we
need to go to somebody else is there
anyone who can supply you with the
amount of air bags that you need well
there are other suppliers but clearly
has an industry we're going to look at
the overall capacity given the Takata
issues and make sure we do the right
thing taking care of the customers have
already bought vehicles will be the
first priority but as an industry of
what look for alternatives but make sure
we also understand what's going on with
the products so I think we don't have
any other issues all right now we can
get back to the flat plane crank it's
something that not a lot of people
understand out there but an easy way to
sort of put it is that that's what
Ferrari uses in a 458 the type of engine
although not that displacement why did
you choose that it's such a special
motor well it changes the performance of
the engine and the feel the engine as
you know and inside with with the kranks
and everything going on 180 degrees
versus 90 degrees it's just true to the
heritage of Mustang and goes back to
what we want to do is take you know take
you back to some of the glory days of
Mustang with the TV
and the 5.2 made a lot of sense it
sounds incredible you know I've always
asked people at Ford why don't you have
something to slot in against Corvette
you've got obviously Mustang being the
big Camaro Challenger but do you think
this does that this a new car but we
think it stands on its own i mean the
the derivative products from Mustang the
g35 einfach gt500 to 350 other products
we've had they have stood out basically
for our enthusiasts for our Mustang
lovers and they're really there on their
own you know Mustang got its own
following and certainly stands on its
own but we like the performance is going
to bring and when people do drive it and
compared to other vehicles I think
they'll be enthused you know yesterday
we saw October sales figures for Europe
and you have an approving situation
there do you forecast that it's going to
come back to normal sooner then maybe we
would have expected previously because
it's starting to look better well it's
getting better but we're not seeing it
improve kind of the rates we saw like
you're not us come back out of this
recession so it's going to be a long
haul here still there's conflicting data
coming out in Europe but we're glad to
see our sales improving clearly on our
channel mix is really improving but we
don't think it's going to be a nice
v-shaped you know come back quickly out
of Europe it's going to be a little bit
longer haul and what about I mean I know
I'm taking you far away from the
Americas which is your main job gig but
you're in the meetings all the time I
mean the Japanese recession caught
everybody by surprise as well is the
asian asian situation kind of eroding
too well we see strong growth in China
still it's slowing down a little bit but
you know seven plus percent gdp growth
in China is still healthy for watching
what's happening in Southeast Asia India
is improving Prime Minister Modi's in
there so there's a mixed bag there but
China is strong India improving you know
and the rest of the economies a you know
look at Africa you look at Middle East
still still improvements to come alright
Joe thanks so much for thanks to see you
Joe Hendrix their president of the ax
men